hi I'm Eric vos and we finally have a
first look at the upcoming Han Solo
movie solo a Star Wars story a trailer
and also a shorter TV spot we're winding
the clock on the galaxy's most
recognizable scoundrel back to when he
was barely recognizable both in the way
he looks and the things he says but hey
Chewie Lando the Falcon woody and the
mother of dragons are all here and this
honestly looks like a lot of fun so
let's run through all of this footage
the trailer and the TV spot to explain
what we're seeing and point out all the
details that you might have missed and
possible spoiler warning if I get any of
these predictions right and let's get
started with the first part of the
trailer
I've been running scams on the streets
since I was 10
just kicked out of flight academy
okay these opening shots show a close-up
of Han Solo's hands as he powers up the
Millennium Falcon now this may be the
first time he even touches these
controls but before we get in context of
this we jump to these shots of a
high-speed chase we get a good look at
alden ehrenreich as a young han and
emilia clark as kira this could be one
of the old scams from the past that Hans
voiceovers alluding to he and Kira look
a lot younger and scruffier than they do
in other shots of the trailer suggesting
that these two might have grown up
together on the streets lifting speeders
kind of like the past and furious but
you know what less CGI right away if you
look closely hanging over the - notice
the golden dice those are Hans lucky
dice and first movie they hung in the
Falcons cockpit and they factored
heavily recently in the last Jedi legend
has it that those dice were used in a
game of Karelian spike a dice variant of
the game Staubach this is the game that
Han played against Lando Calrissian to
win the Millennium Falcon but I'm
guessing that this Chase is before Han
came into possession of the Falcons
maybe these dice were a longtime
good-luck charm which Han would later
use in the game and quickly among the
controls on the dash is a screen with a
similar navigation display as the one in
Luke's x-wing during the Death Star
trench run Hans mission here obviously
seems a lot less noble but considering
how much of a hero Han will later prove
himself to be in that battle it's nice
to get this little reflection of that
future here in his rebellious
fortune-seeking youth let's watch more
of this chase in the next section I mind
my own
I'm gonna be a pilot
best in the galaxy
so the tasting before continues as Han
drifts the speeder along a path across a
wet ocean world dotted with oil platform
looking industrial cities I'm thinking
this could be Corellia Han Solo's
homeworld which we know will be in this
movie meanwhile Hans voice over here
describing his past getting kicked out
of the flight Academy for having a mind
of his own and wanting to be the best
pilot in the galaxy seems like it could
be from another scene that we actually
saw in the TV spot so you want to make a
difference yeah trust me you're gonna
love it which bronze are you interested
in joining I've got a big pilot that's
something out here it looks like Han
Solo is meeting with an imperial
recruitment officer to join the Imperial
Navy if so this is actually fairly
consistent with blonds backstory
according to the Star Wars novels which
are no longer considered Canon but they
make influenced elements of these new
films according to that previous origin
story Han was training to be an imperial
officer and was in charge of slave
shipment including wookies one of those
bookies was Chewbacca and Han helped him
escape defecting from the Empire and
becoming a smuggler we couldn't be seen
some version of that here the TV spot
ends with a shot of Han and Chewie
looking out over this same location so
this all could be part of his rescue
now I had more thoughts on this movies
possible plot later but next we see this
icy mountain range with Han wearing
thick furs in the TV spot there's a shot
of Lando wearing a similar thick coat
but of course looking a lot cooler so
I'm missing that he and Han are on this
mission together and awesome thoughts on
what that mission is exactly at the end
of the video but I'm checking out this
shot of the Falcon interior and notice
how clean and pristine all the surfaces
are compared to the you know familiar
grimy look of the Falcon and other
movies it almost suggests that these
walls are kind of a blank canvas for the
adventurers han will soon embark on most
of which will cover them in grime and
smoke image let's move on
hey kid I'm putting together a crew
okay a lot to talk about here first
there's this shot of Han and Kyra
trekking down the sandy dune and notice
this massive Tower this looks like the
tail end of a vessel that crashed or
washed up into this shoreline long ago
this reminds me a lot of those shots of
the wrecked Star Destroyer and the force
awakens except this wreckage would be
from a different past conflict then Han
meets with Beckett played by Woody
Harrelson he's described as a criminal
and mentor figure to him and noticed how
Beckett greet time hey kid can kind of
hear how hon would later adopt this
paternal tone when talking to Luke I'm
thinking a lot of Hans belief system
could come from this dude they're
standing among these pyramid-shaped
stones I'm not really sure what these
are
maybe tombstones commemorating those who
died in that crash I don't know we'll
see but if you look closely they're
covered in these ancient looking ruins
they don't appear to be written in the
star wars written language of or Abeche
you can kind of make out a few circles
or in English O's with like an L o
underneath it oh my god that's where he
got his name hon Yolo it's worth
pointing out that the marketing for this
movie has really emphasized solo barely
ever mentioning Hans first name my first
thought was that solo in addition to
being his name also applies to Han and
the more thematic level as like a solo
act
I maverick who doesn't really pick a
side but it's just you know stay with me
here since this is kind of the origin
stories showing how Han Solo became Han
Solo what did Han begins this movie
literally nameless or with a completely
different name notice this clip from the
TV spot your name the main characters
starting with the movie name list
wouldn't be completely out of left field
for Star Wars and The Force awakens both
Finn and Rey began their story anonymous
Rey derived her name from an old rebel
helmet belonging to captained Osment rey
whose surname was written on the side
and Finn's name of course is given to
him by Pope that's the only name they
ever gave me
I use a fan huh Finn I'm gonna call you
Finn all right so maybe there's a
version of this movie with hans and anna
midi also factoring into his character
story art any now maybe these runes will
inspire the moniker of solo in some way
or maybe not moving on next there's a
shot of Kira looking older now wearing
makeup and jewelry with a cape and
brooch as if she is back to reclaim the
Iron Throne now my guess is that after
spending their youth together she and
Hans lives took very different paths
like maybe Kira was able to build her
lute with wise investments into a life
of wealth and extravagance
whereas Han would have squandered it
with failed exploits and gambling behind
her is a new droid character apparently
named L 337 which is a reference to late
the old school geek language derived
from elite she's played by actress
Phoebe Waller bridge there's also a shot
of Lando again with Donald Glover
nailing Lando's smooth grin and
laid-back demeanor actually if you look
closely at the later shot of Han
entering the game room you can see Lando
in the background I'm thinking that
these shots could be from that legendary
game queerly and Spike where han won the
Falcon from Lando there are quick shots
of a few other characters Tandy Newton
from West world playing a new character
named Val with a blaster and fur-lined
armor maybe she could be another cohort
from that icy Mountain mission there's
also a new CGI character ha planet gun
turret looking seat if you look closely
this guy has 6 appendages which are
probably a lot more useful to him than
those goggles on his head like why does
everyone wear goggles in these movies
and why are they more often worn on
their foreheads than on their ass like
use them or lose them and then after a
shot of Chewie Han and Beckett there's
my favorite shot of this trailer Lando
and l3 37 giving each other a
synchronized salute and then taking the
Falcon into that iconic hyper speed shot
and maybe I'm just reading into things
but if you noticed that two finger
salute was also done by decade in the TV
spot maybe it's a signal all these guys
figured out ahead of time anyway you
gotta imagine Lando taught the droid how
to do this the way John Connor taught
the Terminator had a high-five guys this
is why robots will never do blue turn
against us they don't like to be teased
let's move on
that might be the only person who knows
what you really are
[Music]
what's that okay next we find ourselves
in this high-end nightclub and if you
look closely there's a dancing Twilight
girl like the one in Jabba's palace in
Return of the Jedi it's possible that
this club might be where Han first meets
Jabba or perhaps his father Zorba the
Hutt who rumor has it was even worse
than Java I'm just thinking that because
if they established things from Hans
past it would be worth seeing how Han
got into debt to the huts in the first
place you notice this set matches the
background of a set photo director Ron
Howard took with Paul Bettany who will
be playing a different motion capture
character in this movie so then we can
assume that he'll be part of the
sequence somehow and then take a look at
this performer she's draped in gold but
her mouth is covered with this device I
think that could be a voice transmitter
from this little dude in the tank to the
left
maybe this body is a surrogate performer
for this less attractive but beautifully
voiced aquatic creature singing from
inside is floating tank kind of like a
Star Wars nightclub version of Krang
from Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles kind
of amazed that hasn't happened yet next
there's a shot of Han unclipping his
blaster holder in the midst of a duel
he's facing off against a group of
bounty hunters a big one facing Han is
the likely villain of this movie
according to the leaked Lego set
featuring character names this looks
kind of like Moloch and I love the
design of this guy this mask appears to
be made from Mandalorian armor that's a
style of armor worn by Boba Fett and the
legends character dark redden but if
you'd look really closely there are some
or Abeche letters on the mask not much
of an aura best linguist but according
to the orbit alphabet the only way these
letters make sense is if you flip this
image horizontally and even then I was
really only able to make out a few
letters the two at the top look like you
would Oh followed by an N and further
down and are now guys my guy says this
will translate into something very
badass and menacing maybe some kind of
warning against those who try to bite
him or the names of those he is hunted
but for the rest of this translation I
put it to you nerdy or nerds than I am
my only help you could see more of
Malakand action in the TV spot fighting
with Beckett on top of a moving train
with this melee weapon he's holding
perhaps an electro staff of sometimes
also if we're addressing that Lego said
malach will be among those pursuing Han
in that speeder chase that we saw before
so maybe this guy's been after Han for a
while looks like there's also gonna be
some adorable creatures called Pirelli
n' hounds next after a shot of a cloaked
figure taking out two guards and a shot
at bell 337 this they believed some
controls we see han piloting a craft
through that mountain range we saw the
four actually if you group all of this
with the footage from the TV spot I
think Hans mission here could be some
heist involving this train that we see
sneaking through the range you look
closely here some ships have attached
ables to one of the boxcars of that
train dangling it through the rocky
passage hey kind of like that safe heist
in Fast Five but I guess with smaller
rocks because the rock is bigger than a
mountain scene the guy is huge I could
see this being a kind of scenario where
Han is faced with some ethical dilemma
like to take the loot or to save some
unfortunate souls and be a good person
all while being chased by malach and his
team of bounty hunters either way I am
stoked to see this heist go down
especially when it looks like it will
end with a massive shockwave explosion
and then there's this exchange between
Kieren Han which for a second evokes Han
and Leia's famous flirtation and Empire
with Kyra saying I know what you are and
Han chuckling and then asking what's had
and then all of us expecting someone to
say a scoundrel but head instead Han
smile fades into a nervous expression
because he doesn't know what he is yet
he's still a scoundrel in training guys
but let's move on to this final section
now we're in trouble there for a second
but it's fun we're fine
who Belize so here the Falcon is
outrunning an imperial star destroyer
and what looks like some kind of nebula
filled with asteroids smokes it is
possible we are looking at the movie
version of the famous Kessel run the
smuggler route that Heine claimed the
Falcon could make in 12 parsecs which I
feel obligated to say is a unit of
distance not time and that because we're
run actually spans 18 parsecs so that
Han was referring to the Falcons
advanced navigational ability not its
speed now the Kessel run is popular with
smugglers because it's a dense asteroid
cluster contained within a nebula arm
and which yes looks a lot like what
we're seeing here maybe this Star
Destroyer has stopped atticus runs
entrance leaving it to the smaller TIE
fighters to continue the chase actually
if you look closely at these you can see
a new variant of a TIE fighter with a
secondary gunner pod beside the central
cockpit meanwhile notice how this early
generation the Falcon hasn't had its
quad laser turrets installed yet so han
has to form a barrel roll to use the
body of the ship to take out a TIE
fighter but as we've seen in every Star
Wars movie there's always a bigger fish
in this case a giant space squid I just
love them ending the trailer this way
it's just a kind of goofy fun that makes
me feel pretty optimistic about this
movie but a question for you guys what
other Star Wars characters do you most
want to show up in this movie now I'm
definitely missing Boba Fett and the
Hutt's but personally I'd be more than
okay if no light sabers or Skywalker's
or Jedi or Sith appears let's just for
once have a true Star Wars story with no
ancient mystical energy controlling its
destiny comment with your thoughts down
below and tweet me directly at you
before following new rock stars for
updates on our videos and subscribe to
this channel for more deep dives into
Star Wars and Star Wars stories we did
in depth breakdowns of the last Jedi
broke one the force awakens so make sure
to go check those out and if you really
like us you can help this channel grow
by contributing to us on patreon big
thanks to all of our donors especially
Alan Fleming guys thanks for watching